ok everyone let's get started for today
ok so we're into week 5
or in and so this is the plan for today
in some sense a lot of this class is
going to be an easy class because I'm
going to talk about things like final
projects and tips for what you're meant
to do and finding a topic and writing up
your work and things like that so far so
2/3 of the class there isn't a lot of
deep technical content but I hope
they're actually just some useful stuff
and stuff that'd be good to know about
one way you can think about this is and
took until this year we had a midterm in
this class so you know if we weren't
doing this class you'd instead be doing
the midterm based on all the material
that we've covered so far so this should
be really Pleasant by comparison but
that isn't going to be quite the entire
class so for this piece here in the
middle I'm gonna spend a while back on
some of the topics of last week so I
wanted to have one more look at some of
these gated recurrent models that Abby
introduced last week and I guess my hope
is that now that you've had a bit more
time to look and read about things and
hopefully even have started working on
homework 4 that maybe it starts to make
a bit more sense or else even if it's
more confusing than before you've got
some idea of what your confusions are in
questions and so hopefully it's good to
think about those one more time because
I think they are quite a complex notion
and it's not so obvious what they're
doing and why they're doing anything
useful or whether they're just this big
complex blob of mystery and then also to
touch on a couple of machine translation
topics that come up in the final project
that we didn't really get time to say
much about last week okay so let's get
started so this is how coursework in
grading that we showed at the beginning
and so the main thing I want to do today
is talk about this final project but
before they I do that let's just say
from one minute on participation so I
guess we start into one aspect of the
participation policy last Thursday
we took attendance that makes it sound
draconian but I wanted to say the
positive viewpoint of the participation
points I mean obviously this is a big
class there are lots of people our hope
is just that people will variously be
sort of engaged and involved in the
class and the participation points our
way of doing that
I mean basically the way this is set up
I mean if you do much of anything you
should just get three percent for the
participation points it shouldn't be
hard I mean I will bet you that there
will be some people who at the end will
have gotten seven points in the
participation category and unfortunately
we cap you will only give you three
percent for the participation category
but you know providing you usually come
to class or usually write the what we've
got to the invited speakers the reaction
paragraphs if you're in SCPD student
sometimes write a helpful answer on
Piazza right you're already going to be
there on three percent yeah and so one
but one other thing there's a way to get
some participation points that's out
today so today we're putting up our mid
quarter feedback survey and we'd love to
have you fill that in I mean we'd like
to get your thoughts on the course so
far and you know for you guys there are
two ways that you can win firstly if
you'd give us some feedback that can
help the rest of your quarter be better
but we've all just so got a simple bribe
built into this which is you get half a
participation point simply fulfilling in
the mid quarter survey but be really
good to get your feedback on that okay
so then the main thing I wanted to get
to today is to talk about the final
project okay and so I'll jump right
ahead into that so for the final project
there are two choices you can either do
our fault final project which I'll say a
little bit about it's doing squad
question answering or you can propose
the final a custom final project which
we then have to approve and in the
course of that if you have some outside
mentor you can say
they are in your project proposal but
otherwise we'll attempt to assign your
mentor somewhere out of the course staff
so for all the assignments through
assignments one through five you have to
do them by yourself for the final
project in either form of it you can do
it as a team so you can do it as one two
or three people and how does that work
well it works like this
if you're a bigger team we do expect you
to do more and there are actually two
ways you can be a bigger team that I'll
point out one way is having more people
being two or three people and the other
thing that comes up is sometimes people
want to do a final project for more than
one class at the same time in particular
for this quarter I know they're at least
a couple of people who are hoping to do
a joint project with Emma's
reinforcement learning class and we
allow that as well but we sort of do
multiplication because if you're two
people using it for two classes that
means it should be four times as great
as what one person is doing for one
class all right so how how it works with
larger teams you know in all honesty
it's a little bit subtle because you
know the truth is if something is just
bad your model was broken or you your
experiment failed and you don't know why
you know if there's just obvious ways in
what you've done as bad as it's sort of
it's sort of bad whether you're one
person or four person and if you've
written it up beautifully you've written
up beautifully regardless of whether
you're one person or four people but you
know nevertheless the expectation is
that if you're one person will be
pleased that if you put together one
model and gotten it to work well but if
you're three people will say well that
wasn't such a big effort running this
one model against this tassel if there
are three people they could have
investigated some other model classes
and seeing whether they perform better
or worse on this task and will feel as
then sort of lightweight so we are
expecting that sort of
more ambitious projects and more
thorough exploration of them if you're
being a bigger team or you're using it
for multiple classes for the final
project you are allowed to use any
language or deep learning framework that
you choose to we don't insist on what
you use now in practice in past years
basically everyone keeps on using what
they've learned in the assignments I
expect that will be true this time as
well okay so let me just mention quickly
the default final project so that you've
got some sense of context so the
materials of that will be released this
Thursday and so for the task for it is a
textual question answering task which is
done over the the Stanford question
answering data sets squad which was a
data set put together by Percy Liang in
the department and the student
so we've used this as a default final
project before but we're mixing up a
couple of things this year
I mean firstly the starter code we're
providing this year is in pay torch to
fit in with what we've done for the rest
of the class but secondly the squad team
released a new version of squad squad
2.0 and we're going to use that for the
class this year and the essential
difference in squad 2.0 is in squad 1.1
or 1.0 every question had an answer in
the passage of text whereas in squad 2.0
a lot of questions don't have answers so
there's this extra significant thing
that you need to do which is working out
whether a question has an answer so this
is just one example which just gives you
a sense of a SWAT squad is like so
there's a paragraph of text I've just
put a subset of it here bill akin
adopted by Mexican movie actress Lupe
mayoría grew up in the neighborhood town
neighboring so a neighboring town of
Madera and his song chronicled the
hardships faced by the migrant farm
workers he saw as a child right there's
then a question in what town did bill
way actually I miss spelt that so it
should have been Aiken without and I I
got confused with our former department
chair Alex akin I guess when I was
typing bill Aiken grow up and the answer
you're meant to give is Madera so just
incidentally as a random fact so quite a
few of you know about something there
was recently in the kind of tech new
tech news and we're going to talk that
later in the class that people from
Google produced this very strong new
natural language understanding
representation model called Burt and
which is one of several kind of models
that are in a class of models that
contextually model words that have come
into prominence in 2017 and 18 and in
general Burt has sort of produced very
good performance for very many tasks
indeed if you look at the squad 2.0
leaderboard online at this URL
what you'll find is that all of the
leading systems use but in some way or
another these days but nevertheless this
was actually a question that Burt got
wrong that Burt said no answer to this
question rather than getting the correct
answer even though it looks kind of
straightforward reading it as a human
being it doesn't really look a human
tricky reading comprehension question so
that's the default final project so on
Thursday I'm going to talk more about
the default final project I'm going to
talk about how people build textual
question answering systems and the
details on the default final project
should all be posted by them but that's
just to give you a bit of context of
what the other choice is and today I'm
sort of more going to be aiming at
people doing the custom final project
but let me just sort of say a bit first
about the choice between the two of them
so why might you want to choose the
default final project so if you have
limited experience with research you
don't have any clear idea of a research
project you want to do this quarter you
know just really busy with other classes
that are you're enrolled in CS 140 and
you're just really loading left in
pattern with other classes you're doing
this quarter you'd be happy to have just
a clear goal towards to work towards and
leaderboard if your fellow students that
you can compete against do the default
final project I think for many people
it's actually the good right choice and
I mean for what it's worth I mean
typically slightly over half of people
have done the default final project it's
normally about sort of 55 percent have
done the final project and the rest of
custom final project so if you do the
default final project you get lots of
guidance you get lots of scaffolding
there are clear things to aim at and
what you do the course staff are in
general most prepared and most able to
help you and in particular I mean the
for the bottom bullet here I mean you
know something to think about and making
the choices that some of it comes down
to how committed organized and keen are
you to be wanting to do
your own custom final project if you've
got something you really want to do for
a custom final project great we love to
see interesting custom final projects
but you know if you're going to end up
doing something that just looks worse
like not done as well as you would have
done a data project if you just done the
default final project then you should
probably change the default final
project okay but even if you are you
doing the thing you'll do the default
final project I hope that some of this
lecture will still be useful well the
part in the middle when I talk back
about empty and gated recurrent networks
will definitely useful but you know
beyond that some of the tips on doing
research and discussions of sort of
looking at how to make newer networks
work and our analysis paper writing
these are all good topics that apply to
the default final project as well so in
the other direction if you have some
research project that you're excited
about possible it's one you're already
working on or possibly that you've just
always wished to do something exciting
with your networks and rap music well
you know the custom final project is an
opportunity to do that so it's a chance
for you to do something on your own if
you know obviously if you're not
interested in textual question-answering
but you think you might like machine
translation well it's an opportunity to
choose any topic of your own it's also a
way to sort of experience much more of
the research process because you know
for the default final project it's a
bigger more open-ended thing than any of
our assignments but you know
nevertheless the default final project
is still sort of a pre set up thing that
you don't have to find your own problem
find your own data work out a good
approach to it a lot of that sort of
been done for you so that for a custom
final project is much more your own job
to sort of define and execute a mini
research project and so all of that
stuff seems appealing while some of it
seems appealing then aim at the custom
final project doing this just reminded
me about a fact about assignments one to
five you know for assignments one to
five
we are hoping that they can be a set of
stepping stones for learning how to
build deep learning systems but you know
one of our goals in that is to give you
less handholds as time goes by so you
know assignment one was really easy and
assignment three we tried to make it
really handhold e so people could start
to learn PI torch but you know we're
actually hoping for a silence four and
five that they're actually harder so
that you're getting more experience of
working out how to build and do things
by yourself because if the only thing
you ever see is completely scaffolded
assignments it's sort of like when you
do CS 106a that you have do a great job
on the CS 106a assignments but you don't
really know how to write a program by
yourselves and that's sort of what we
want to sort of get you beyond in the
letter to assignment so I hope you have
started on assignment four if not you
really should start and get underway
soon as Evie was emphasizing okay so
this year for the final project
whichever one you're doing we're
actually putting more structure in than
we have in previous years to encourage
people to get going and so in particular
there are early on components which are
worth points in the grading so the first
part of that is a project proposal which
is we want from each team so one per
team you can just do a joint one which
is worth 5% so it's releasing the
details on Thursday which is when
assignment four is due and it'll be due
the following Thursday so we're actually
having an interruption in the sequence
of current assignments right so for the
next week what the thing to do is
project proposal and then the week after
that we're back to assignment five and
then we go full-time into final project
so what we're wanting for the project
proposal is we're actually wanting you
to do a little bit of starting off
research in the final terms of reading
some paper so find some paper that's
relevant to your research that you're
going to do
reader write a summary of what it does
write down some thoughts on how you
could adapt or extend ideas in it in
your own final project and then say
something about what your plan is for
what you're hoping to do for your final
project and especially if you're doing a
custom final project there's more to
write there because we'll want to make
sure that you have some ideas of what
data you can use and how you're going to
evaluate it whereas a couple of those
things are actually sort of determined
for you if you're doing the default
final project and so then after that
we're going to have a project milestone
which is the progress report where we're
hoping that you can report that you're
well along in your final project that
you've run at least some experiment and
have some results on some data then you
can talk about so the default the
project milestone is due on Thursday
March 7 so it's actually more than
halfway through the period that's sort
of dedicated to the final project so if
you're not we sort of put a past halfway
because the fact of the matter is it
always takes people time to get going
but nevertheless you know what you
should have in your head is unless
you're halfway through by the time
you're handing in your project milestone
then you're definitely behind and you'll
be doing that typical standard thing of
having a lot of late nights and lack of
sleep in the last week of class trying
to catch up for that okay so so now I
sort of want to sort of just start
saying a bit of you know for custom
final projects of some of the sort of
thinking and types of things that you
could do about that so you have to
determine some project four or five if
you're doing a custom final project so
in philosophy of science you know there
are basically two ways for any field you
can have a project you either start with
some domain problem of interest
you're just got something you're
interested in of saying you know gee I'd
like to do better than machine
translation and then you work out some
ways to address it with technology or
you start with some technical approach
of interest
and you say oh well those LS TM seem
kind of neat but I didn't understand why
this that extra 10 H and I think it'd be
better if it changed in this other way
and you start exploring from a technical
direction to try and come up with a
better idea and then you're wanting to
prove that it works so in kinds of the
projects that people do for this class
this isn't quite an exhaustive list but
this is sort of in general what people
do so the first category and really I
think this is the bulk of projects over
half is people find some task or
application of interest and they build
some neural network models to try and do
it as effectively as possible there's a
second category where people sort of
concentrate on implementing so
reimplemented some complex neural
architecture and getting it to work on
some data and so let me just say a
couple of sentences on this so it's
certainly okay for you to start by
reimplemented some existing model and
some people that's as far as they get
and then the question is is that okay
and the answer to whether that's okay
sort of largely depends on how complex
your neural model is so if what you
think is okay I'm going to re-implement
something like we've seen already like a
window based classification model and
you just really implement that and run
it on some data and get some results and
stop that's definitely a bad project but
there are lots of very complicated and
sophisticated neural architectures out
there and if you're trying to do
something complicated well then that can
be a fine project so I actually sort of
stuck in a few examples of projects so I
mean here's one that was actually from a
couple of years ago so this was in the
2017 class and so shortly before the
2017 class deepmind who's one of the
organizations producing the most
complicated new
models had just released a paper about
the differentiable neural computer model
which was a model of how to have
something like a differential
differentiable Turing machine like
architecture inside a neural network
this would be a great challenge to try
and reimplemented if ur n chable neural
computer which deepmind hadn't released
any source code for because they're not
the kind of place that generally
releases their source code and you know
this was actually an extremely ambitious
project because it was it's a very
complex architecture which is hard to
get to train and so you know at the end
at the end she hadn't been able to sort
of train as bigger model or get as good
results as they reported in the paper
but you know frankly we thought it was
pretty miraculous that she managed to
get it working at all
in the period of time we had in the
class and she did successfully do an
open source free implementation of this
model which basically work the same as
in their paper they're not quite as well
so you know that seemed a huge
achievement so you certainly can do
something of that sort right so so you
you can sort of from a technical
direction have some ideas for a variant
model and explore how to make a
different kind of model class and then
look at how it works on some problem
that works well another kind of project
you can do is an analysis project so
that you might be interested in
something a natural language or
something on the behavior of neural
networks and just think that you want to
analyze them more closely so you might
think oh maybe these neural machine
translation systems work great providing
the word order is the same and the
source and target language but can they
really do a good job of reordering
phrases for different language types how
much does their performance vary based
on the amount of reordering between the
source and target language and you could
do some experiments to try and
investigate that as an analysis problem
that looks at a model and we sometimes
gets projects like that down the bottom
is the rarest kind of project which is
when some people try to do something
theoretical which is to prove some
properties of a system so this is
easiest to do in simple systems for
something like word vectors that if you
might want to prove something about the
kind of spaces that are induced by word
vectors and what properties you need to
have in models from word analogies to
work or something like that I'm here
just another couple of examples that
sort of show some of the other classes
so this one is an example of find a
problem and build some models so these
three people looked at Shakespearean
sonnet generation and then they
considered several different models for
a Shakespearean sonnet generation and
got the best results from this sort of
you probably can't really see all the
details but they have a sort of a
mixture of word level and character
level gated model that feeds into a word
level LS TM and produces sonnets and the
output wasn't totally bad thy youth time
and face his form shall cover now all
fresh Beauty my love there will ever
time to greet forget each like ever
decease but in it but in a best at
worship his glory died okay it's maybe
not perfect but it sort of sounds like a
Shakespearean sonnet
okay yeah so I showed you that one
already here's an example of someone who
designed a different kind of network and
this was a project that came out of this
class that was then continued with and
that they got a conference paper out of
at the iclear 2017 paper so this was
looking at doing a better job at
building a neural language model and
essentially they had two ideas both of
which seem useful for building better
neural language models and so one is
that in the stuff that we presented so
far whether it was the early word
vectors or what Abby presented last week
in the neural language model there are
effectively two vectors for each word
there's one for the word encoding on the
import and then when you have the
softmax on the other side effectively
the rows of that matrix that go into the
softmax are also word vectors for
determining how likely you are to
produce different words and so these two
people had the idea that maybe if we
actually in the model tie those two word
bit vectors together that would help and
produce a better model and
and so this was actually done several
years ago when that was a novel idea
which hadn't actually been done - this
was done the 2016 class and then they
had this second idea which was well
maybe doing the kind of cross-entropy
one-zero sort of you look at the correct
word that you're meant to produce and
sort of work out a loss based on that
maybe that's not very good because you
don't get partial points if you produce
a different word that's semantically
similar and so that they had this idea
that they could use word vector
similarity and then you'd be giving a
score for any word that was produced
next based on how similar it was
according to word vector similarity to
the word that you were meant to produce
next and that was also a useful idea
that they were able to produce improved
language models with so that was a cool
project here's an example of somebody
from last year who did an analysis
project so their idea was that they well
they're going to evaluate on some tasks
they actually did several Tartus word
similarity analogy and a squad and
question-answering system but the
question was okay a lot of neural
network models are big and so aren't
very suitable for phones could we get
away with compressing the models a lot
so that rather than having doubles or
32-bit floats or even 16-bit floats and
now use quite a bit in neural networks
could we compress a lot more and
quantize our numeric values so that we
could only be say using two bits for per
parameter so they're literally only four
bits per parameter and if you do that
naively it doesn't work but if you
explore some cleverer ways of doing it
and see how to make things work you can
actually get to work really well in fact
it actually seems like sometimes you can
improve your performance doing this
because the quantization acts as a form
of a regularizer you can find lots of
other projects online if you look at the
cs2 24in pages and you should okay
so if you want to do a final project you
have to find someplace to start you know
one place is to start looking at papers
there's online anthology of most of the
NLP conference papers you can look at
MML conferences have lots of relevant
papers as well you can look at past CS
2:24 in papers that cover lots of topics
so you know I don't also forget the
advice down the bottom which is look for
an interesting problem in the world so
else
Stanford's yes emeritus professor ed
Feigenbaum likes to quote the advice of
his adviser herb Simon of if you see a
research area where many people are
working goes somewhere else well you
know in the context of this class don't
go so far away that you're not using
neural networks or NLP because that
won't work for projects for this class
but you know nevertheless I mean in some
sense it's a bad strategy of saying
let's look at all the papers that were
published last year and let's what start
working on one of their problems or lots
of people are working on question
answering I'll do it too you know there
are lots of interesting different
problems in the world and if you know of
some you know cool website that somehow
does something interesting related to
language you know maybe you can make a
final project out of that other ways to
find final projects so the person who's
first put together most of the CS 231 in
content was Andrew and Rekha pothi who
now works at Tesla and among his other
things he did for the world he put
together this site archive sanity
preserver which is a way to find online
archive papers which is a major preprint
server and if you say a few papers
you're interested in and I'll show you
other papers that you're interested in
they'll show you papers they're
currently trending so that can be a good
way to look if you think it'd be just
good to be in some competition where
you're in wanting to build a system
that's better than other peoples you can
look at leaderboards for various tasks
so this is brand new site which is
pretty good though not completely
error-free incorrect of people
with code comm and it collects a whole
lot of leaderboards for a whole lot of
machine learning tasks including tons of
language ones so it gives leaderboards
for question answering machine
translation named entity recognition
language modeling how to speech hanging
all sorts of tasks you can find there
and find out what current states BR and
datasets are ok so you know different
projects are different but often for a
lot of projects the things you need to
be making sure of is it's something that
you can get a decent amount of data
about so you can train a model
it's a feasible task it's not so
enormous you can't possibly do it in
four weeks you'll want to have some
evaluation metric and normally for deep
learning you have to have even if you
hope to do some human evaluation as well
you have to have some automatic
evaluation metric because unless there's
just some code that you can run that
gives you a score for how well you're
doing then unless you have that you just
sort of can't do the deep learning trick
of saying okay let's do back propagation
to optimize our scores according to this
metric and pretty much you'll want to do
that to be able to do neural network
optimization and we do require that
there's an important part of NLP in your
class project I mean it doesn't have to
be the only thing you could be doing
reinforcement learning as well or you
could do images to caption so doing
joint vision end NOP but there has to be
NLP in it okay last bit before I get
back onto the content from last week so
something that you'll need to do is have
data for your project so some people
collect their own data for a project and
you know it's not impossible to collect
your own data especially if there's
something you can do with unsupervised
data you might be able to get it by just
sort of crawling an interesting website
you can annotate a small amount of data
yourself if you have any site that has
some kind of you know ratings annotation
stars on it you can treat those as a
form of annotation
right so if you want to predict
something like you know which
descriptions on product review websites
which reviews on product review websites
to people like well they get star
ratings at the bottom from people and
then you can try and fit to that as your
supervision sometimes people have data
from an existing project for a company
you can use that but nevertheless for
most people given that classes are short
and things like that
the practical thing to do is use an
existing curated data set that's been
built by previous researchers that
normally gives you a fast start and lets
you get to work building models there's
obvious prior work there are baselines
and previous systems that you can
compare your performance on etc okay so
where can you find data I'll just
mention a couple of places here and
there are lots more so traditionally the
biggest source of linguistic data used
by academics was this place called the
linguistic data consortium and they have
lots of data sets for tree banks and
named entities and coreference parallel
machine translation data etc etc and so
the linguistic data Consortium licenses
their data stanford pays that license so
you can use any of it but if you want to
use it you go to that linguistics dot
stanford.edu page and there's a sign up
piece on how to sign up where you
basically say I will use this data only
for good Stanford purposes and not as
the basis of my startup and then you can
have access to that data and it can be
made available by FS or otherwise but as
time has gone by there's a ton of
curated NOP data that's available on
various websites in fact if anything the
problem is it's just sort of spread over
the web and it's sort of hard to find
different things but there are some that
some sites that have a lot of data for
various purposes so anything related to
machine translation or just parallel
data across different languages the
statistical empty state
t-dog side has a great amount of data
and that organization runs shared tasks
every year the workshop on machine
translation WMT which Abby already
mentioned in her class and they've got
datasets that we use for those tasks and
then there are leaderboards for those
tasks and you can find data for that if
you thought dependency parsing was cool
there's the universal dependencies side
which has power it's not parallel sorry
which has tree banks in the same
annotation scheme for about 60 different
languages and you can work on parsers
for different languages and things like
that
I'm not going to bore you with going
through all of them but you know there
are just tons and tons of other data
sets that Facebook has release data say
it's Google's release data say its
assets Stanford have released several
other data sets including the Stanford
sentiment tree Bank and the Stanford net
natural language inference corpus and
new question-answering data sets
including hotpot QA and conversational
question-answering other groups at
different universities of release
datasets there are just tons of them you
can find data on sites like Kegel where
it has machine learning competitions
there are sites with lists of data sets
you can look at research papers and see
what data sets they used and of course
you can ask the core staff Ron Piazza to
try and find suitable data sets for a
project ok so that's a fair bit about
the project so I've got a bit more to
say later about doing projects does
anyone have any questions up until now
on projects ok well so now we're going
to sort of flip a switch in our brains
and go back and have one more look at
gated recurrent units and what happens
and what they mean and you know this is
sort of sort of the same material that
ABI presented presented a little bit
differently but you know I hope it might
just sort of give one more way of sort
of thinking a bit about what's happening
about these gated recurrent units and
why they might be doing
something useful and what are the
alternatives to them so if you remember
the problem we started with is that we
want it to understand sort of
derivatives backward in time and so the
idea of that is well if we twiddle this
a little bit at time T how much effect
is that going to have so we make some
adjustment here how much effect is that
going to have end time steps later and
well we sort of looked at the
derivatives and we sort of saw we got
these terms for each successive time
step and so as a be discussed the
problem is that for the derivatives that
we got we kind of got this matrix form
for each time step and so that if we
were going through a lot of time steps
we got a lot of matrix multiplies and as
the result of those matrix multiplies
pretty much either things disappear down
to zero or explode it upward depending
on what was in the matrix and so that
and so that sort of means week when the
gradient goes to zero we kind of can't
know what's happening is there if
whether there isn't any conditioning or
just we can't measure it and so that
sort of made people think that maybe
this naive recurrent neural network
transition function just isn't a good
one to use and that sort of leads into
these ideas of gated recurrent units
right because if we have the simple
recurrent neural network where we're
sort of feeding forward for each step in
time well what happens is when we back
propagate we have to back propagate
through every intermediate node and
that's where we sort of have our
gradients disappear and so an idea of
how you could fix that is to say well
suppose we just put in direct
connections that were longer distance
then we'd also get direct back
propagation signal and so then we
wouldn't have this same problem of
vanishing gradients and effectively
we've sort of looked at two ways in
which you can achieve
effect because one way of you can
achieve that effect which Abby looked at
in the end part of the last lecture was
this idea of attention so when you've
got attention you're actually are
creating these shortcut connections oops
they're the blue ones from every time
step and using it to calculate an
attention distribution but the way the
attention was done that we looked at he
was sort of mushing together all
previous time steps into some kind of an
average but the idea of the gated
recurrent units is in some sense we want
to achieve this same kind of ability to
have shortcut connections but we want to
do it in a more controlled and adaptive
fashion where we still do remember the
position of things so how can we create
an adaptive shortcut connection and so
that's what we start to do with the
gates that are put into a gated
recurrent Network so if so first off we
sort of say let's have a candidate
update which is exactly the same as the
one that's used in a simple recurrent
neural network but what we can do is add
a gate and so the gate will calculate a
value from 0 to 1 and so what we're
going to do here is mix together using
our candidate update which is just like
a simple recurrent neural network which
will be then mixed together with simply
directly carrying forward the hidden
state from the previous time step so
once we're doing that we are sort of
then adaptively we're adaptively partly
using a computation from one time step
back done as a recurrent neural network
and we're partly just inheriting the
we're just part sorry we're partly
inheriting the hidden state from the
previous time step so it's sort of like
a shortcut connection but we're waiting
as to how much we're shortcutting and
how much we're doing our comp
and we control that adaptive choice by
using a calculation to set the gate and
we do that with a sigmoid computed over
the import and the hidden previous
hidden state and using again an equation
kind of like a simple recurrent neural
network okay but you know if you wanted
to go a bit further than that you could
think well maybe sometimes we sort of
might actually just want to get rid of
the stuff that was in the past that
maybe the stuff in the past sometimes
becomes irrelevant like maybe sometimes
we start a new sentence or a new thought
and we just want to get rid of the stuff
that's in the past and so that can lead
into this idea of having a second gate
and reset gate and so the reset gate
calculates a value for 0 to 1 just like
the other gates and then we're doing
this element-wise dot product between
the reset gate and the previous hidden
state and that's then sort of saying
well maybe we want to keep some parts of
what was stored previously and some
parts that we now want to throw away and
so we put that into the model as a
second gate and so an interesting way to
think about that is to sort of think
about this as if this recurrent neural
network is like a little tiny computer
of the kind of little tiny computers you
might do in a sort of simple
architecture class and if you think
about it that way for the basic simple
recurrent neural network the way the
tiny computer works is that you've got a
bank of registers H your hidden state
and at each time step you have to read
at each time step you have to read the
entirety of your bank of registers you
do some computation and then you write
the entirety of your bank of registers
and you know if in terms of thinking
about computer architecture that sounds
like a pretty bad way to implement a
simple computer so precisely what a
gated recurrent unit is doing is saying
well maybe we have a slightly more
sophisticated little baby computer
instead of that we could select a subset
of the registers that we want to read
and so the reset gate can control that
because it can say well just ignore a
bunch of the other registers if then
we'll compute a new value based on just
these stored registers and then the
update gate which is also adaptive can
say well I want you to write some
registers but the rest of the registers
will just keep their previous value that
seems a useful idea to have in a
computer and so that's what we're doing
here and so this model here is what was
from a be presented second as the gated
recurrent unit so this sort of a much
more realistic model and it's sort of in
some sense overlaps with the ideas of
attention
okay so gated recurrent units are
actually a quite new model the model
that was done way earlier Anne's had
huge impact is these LS TM long
short-term memory units and they're a
bit more complex but you know a lot of
it's sort of the same right so the
hidden state of a gated recurrent unit
is kind of equivalent to the cell of the
LST M so both of them are using the same
idea of summing together a mixture of
just directly interpret directly
inheriting what you had from the
previous time step together with
something that you've calculated for the
current time step and the way you can't
calculate it for the current time step
is exactly the same in both cases a
groups sorry both cases again that
you're calculating the current update
using this sort of simple are in
equation so those parts are exactly the
same but the LST M is a little bit more
complicated it now has three gates and
it's got this extra hidden state that's
then worked out with a bit more
complexity so in terms of my lsdm
picture you know the l STM picture looks
if you sort of pull apart all of its
math pretty complex but so there are
three gates so that you can forget or
ignore everything so you can forget or
ignore the input you can forget or
ignore parts of your previous hidden
state and you can forget or ignore parts
of the cell when calculating the output
and each of these is produce when I say
forget or ignore parts of what that's
meaning is you're calculating a vector
which is then going to be element wise
multiplied by the import of the previous
hidden state or the cell and so that's
where you have this effect of now an
addressable bank of registers where you
can use some of them and not others of
them okay so the bottom part of the LS
TM is just like a simpler simple
recurrent neural network which then
calculates a candidate update and so for
both of the GI you and the LS TM the
real secret is that rather than just
keeping on multiplying stuff what you do
is you add two things together and so
this adding is why you don't get the
same vanishing gradient evil effects
because you're calculating a new
candidate update and you're adding it to
stuff that was previously in the cell
and that gives you a simple gradient
when you back propagate back that you
have a direct linear connection between
the cell at time T and the cell at time
T minus one and so really that simple
addition there are sort of the secret of
most of the power of LS TMS and the same
idea of adding two things together has
also been a secret of many of the other
advances and deep learning recently so
envision and last couple of years
is the sort of standard model that
everybody uses as resonates residual
networks and they use exactly the same
secret of allowing these adaptive
updates where you add together a current
layers value with directly inheriting a
value from the layer below other things
that use similar ideas or things like
highway networks and so on so that's
proven to be an extremely powerful idea
the LS TM is slightly different from the
GRU because when we look back at its
equations that the the giu kind of does
a linear mixture where you have one gate
value UT and 1 minus UT where the lsdm
adds values controlled by two different
gates of forget gate and an input gate
theoretically having the adding of two
separate gates rather than a mixture is
theoretically more powerful depending on
the application sometimes it doesn't
seem to make much difference but there's
definitely a theoretical advantage to
the lsdm there okay there's I hope
that's maybe a little bit more helpful
to seeing those again any questions on
gated recurrent units still look
confusing and I think it's useful to
have some kind of idea as to why the
people come up with these things and why
do they make sense but you know
nevertheless the reality is in the sort
of era of 2015 plus any deep learning
package you use whether it's PI Tosh
tensorflow remix net whatever you know
it just comes with LST M's and Gi use
and you don't have to program your own
in fact your disadvantage if you program
your own because if you're using the
built-in one it's using and of efficient
CUDA kernel from Nvidia whereas your
custom-built one won't and all run three
times slower
so you know in a sense you don't have to
know how to do it and you can just take
the attitude that an LS TM is just like
a fancy recurrent Network which will be
easier to train and that's true but you
know these kind of architectural ideas
have actually been central to most of
the big advances that come and deep
learning in the last couple of years so
there's actually good to have an idea to
have some sense of what were these
important ideas that made everything so
much better first they're the same kind
of component building blocks you might
also want to use in custom models that
you design for yourself okay two bits of
machine translation so a bit of machine
translation that we sort of didn't cover
next week but lots of people been seeing
and getting confused by in the
assignment so I thought I'd explain a
bit about is unk's
and explain where do I come from
and why are there unk's and the reason
why they're unk's is effectively kind of
for efficiency reasons so if you sort of
think about producing output in a neural
machine translation system and really
this is the same as producing output in
any natural neural natural language
generation system so it's really the
same for a neural language model that if
you have a very large output vocabulary
it's just as expensive operation so you
have a big matrix of softmax parameters
where you have a row for every word and
then you have weight then we have an
animation that is not working for me oh
oh wait there we go so then we have some
hidden state that we've calculated in
our recurrent neural network and so what
we're going to do is sort of multiply
that vector by every row of the matrix
put it through a soft Max and then get
probabilities of out putting every
word and you know this seems pretty
simple but the problem is that to the
extent that you have a humongous
vocabulary here you just have to do a
humongous number of rows of this
multiplication and it actually turns out
that doing this is the expensive part of
having a new or machine translation on
your language model system right the LS
TM might look complicated and hard to
understand but you know it's relatively
small vectors that you multiply or dot
product once and it's not that much work
whereas if you have a huge number of
words this is a huge amount of work so
just for instance sort of for the pyre
innit pioneering sequence the sequence
newer machine translation system that
Google first did they ran it on an 8 GPU
machine because they have lots of GPUs
but the way they set it up to maximize
performance was of those 8 GPUs three of
them were running a deep multi-layer
neural sequence model and the other five
GPUs the only thing that they were doing
was calculating soft Nexus because
that's actually the bulk of the
computation that you need to be able to
do so the simplest way to make this
computation not completely excessive is
to say hey I'll just limit the
vocabulary yeah I know that you can make
a million different words in English and
if you look at Spanish inflections and
verbs there are a lot of them and
there's going to be a huge number of
words but maybe I can just make do with
a modest vocabulary and it'll be near
enough surely fifty thousand common
words I can cover a lot of stuff and so
that was sort of the starting off point
of neural machine translation that's you
people use the modest vocabulary like
around fifty thousand words and well if
you do that well then what happens is
you have unk's
so unk means this is an unknown word
that's not in my vocabulary and so there
are two kinds of unk's there can be
unk's in the source language and you
know there
sort of optional because you know it's
not actually a problem having a large
source language vocabulary but the fact
of the matter is if you've sort of
trained a model on a certain amount of
data there are some words you aren't
going to have seen so you are going to
have words that you just didn't see in
your training data and you won't have
any pre trained or trained word vector
for them and you can deal with that by
either just treating them as ants or
giving them a new word vector when you
encounter them but the tricky part is on
the translation that you're wanting to
produce these rare words but they're not
in your output vocabulary so your system
is producing lung cancer UNK which is
not a very good translation really yeah
and so that was sort of what the first
machine Trenton neural machine
translation systems did and so yeah
obviously that's not a very satisfactory
state of affairs and so there's been a
whole bunch of work as to how to deal
with this so you can use methods that
allow you to deal with a larger output
vocabulary without the computation being
excessive so one method of doing that is
to have what's called a hierarchical
softmax so that rather than just having
a huge matrix of words you sort of have
a tree structure in your vocabulary so
you can do calculations with
hierarchical multiple small soft maxes
and you can do that more quickly I'm not
going to go through all these exams all
these things in detail now and just sort
of very quickly mentioning them and if
anyone's interested they can look people
have used the noise contrast of
estimation idea that we saw with word to
Veck in this context as well so this is
a way to get much faster training which
is important it's not really a way to
solve speed at translation time but you
know if this means you can train your
system in six hours instead of six days
that's a big win and so that's a good
technique to use people have done much
smarter things so really the large
vocabulary problem is basically solved
now and so the kind of
things that you can do is you can
produce subsets of your vocabulary and
train on particular subsets of
vocabulary at a time and then when
you're testing you adaptively choose
kind of a likely list of words that
might appear in the translation of
particular sentences or passages and
then you can effectively work with the
sort of an appropriate subset of the
vocabulary and that's sort of an
efficient technique by which you can
deal with an unlimited vocabulary but
only be using a moderate-sized softmax
for any particular paragraph that you're
translating that's a paper that talks
about that method another idea is you
can use attention when you do
translation the idea talked about at the
end of last time so if you have
attention that sort of means that you
can you're pointing somewhere in the
source and you know what you're
translating at any point in time so if
that word is a rare word that's not in
your vocabulary there are things that
you could do to deal with that I mean
firstly if it's a rare word its
translation is much more likely to be
constant so you might just look it up in
a dictionary or word list and stick in
its translation sometimes it's
appropriate to do other things
I mean turns out that you know quite a
lot of things that unknown words turn
out to be other things like you know
hexadecimal numbers of FedEx tracking
IDs or github chars or things like that
so for a lot of things like that the
right thing to do is just to copy them
across and so another thing that people
have looked at is copying models in
machine translation okay there are more
ideas that you can we can get into to
solve this and actually next week we're
going to start dealing with some of the
other ways that you could solve this but
I hope there to have given you sort of a
sense of sort of what these unk's are
about why you see them and that there
are sort of some ways that you might
deal with them but you're not expected
to be doing that for assignment four
okay then I just wanted to give a teeny
bit more on evaluation so Abby said a
little bit
about evaluation with blue and that then
comes up in the assignment so I just
thought I'd give you a little bit more
context on that since there have been
quite a few questions about it so so the
general context here is you know how do
you evaluate machine translation quality
and sort of to this day if you want to
do a first-rate bang-up evaluation a
machine translation quality the way you
do it is you get human beings to assess
quality you take translations and you
send them to human beings with good
bilingual skills and get them to score
things and there are two ways that are
commonly used one is sort of rating on
Likert scales for things like adequacy
and fluency of translations but another
way that often works better is asking
for comparative judgement so here are
two translations of this sentence which
is better and so that's you know sort of
still our gold standard of translation
another way you can evaluate
translations use your translations in
the downstream tasks so you could say
I'm going to build a cross lingual
question answering system and in that
side that system I'm going to use
machine translation I'm going to
translate the questions and then try and
match them against the documents and
then my score will be how good my
question answering system is and so the
machine translation system is better if
my question answering score goes up I
mean that's kind of a nice way to do
things because she was kind of then
taking an end run around needing needing
human beings and yet you do have a clear
numerical measure that's coming out the
back end but it sort of has some
catchers because you know often there'll
be a fairly indirect connection between
your end tasks and the quality of the
machine translation and it might turn
out there are certain aspects of the
machine translation like whether you get
agreement endings right on nouns and
verbs or something they're actually just
irrelevant to your performance in the
task and so you're not assessing all
aspects of quality and so then the third
wave to do it is to come up
with some way to score the direct task
so here the direct task isn't machine
translation and this has been a valuable
tool for you know really the lasts of 25
years when people are doing machine
learning models because as soon as you
have an automatic way to score things
you can then run automated experiments
to say let me try out these 50 different
options let me start varying these hyper
parameters and work out which way to do
things as best and that importance has
only grown in the deep learning era when
all the time what we want him to do is
as a be discussed build into end systems
and then back propagate throughout the
entire system to improve them and we're
doing that based on having some
objective measure which is our automatic
metric and so that led into the
development of automatic metrics to try
and assess machine translation quality
and the most famous and still most used
one is this one called blue and so as I
been briefly mentioned we have a
reference translation done by human
beings at some time a human being has to
translate each piece of source material
once but then you take a machine
translation and you score it based on
the extent of which there are one or
more word sequences that appear in the
reference translation and also appear in
the machine translation and so you're
working out in grandpa's precision
scores for different values of n so the
standard way of doing it is you do it
4-1 grams by grams trigrams and four
grams so word sequences of size one to
four and you try and find four ones of
those in the machine translation whether
they also appear in the reference
translation and there are two tricks at
work here one trick is you have to do a
kind of a bipartite matching because it
just can't be that there's a word
in this in the reference translation
somewhere don't know if there's I've got
a good example here maybe I can only do
a silly example but I'll do a silly
example that if it doesn't seem like you
want to say okay because this is that in
the reference that means that this that
is right and this that is right and this
that is right and every other that is
also right that sort of seems unfair so
you're only allowed to use each thing in
the reference once in matching engrams
but you are allowed to use it multiple
times for different order engrams so you
can use it both Annie unigram bigram
trigram and for Graham the other idea is
that although you're measuring the
precision of engrams that are in the
machine translation you wouldn't want
people to be able to cheat by putting
almost nothing into the machine
translation so you might want to game it
by no matter what the source document is
if the target languages English you
could just say my translation is that
that because I'm pretty sure that will
be in the reference translation
somewhere and I'll get points for a
unigram and that's not great but I'll
get something for that and I am done and
so you wouldn't want that and so you're
then being penalised by something called
the brevity penalty if your translation
is shorter than the reference
translation and so this blue metric is
forming a geometric average of in gram
precision up to some in normally it's
sort of up to four is how it's done
where it's a weighted geometric average
where you're putting weights on the
different engrams for the assignment
we're only using you know grams and buy
grams so you could say that means we're
going a weight of zero on the try grams
and four grams okay and so that's
basically what we're doing I'll just
mention a couple of other things you
might think that this is kind of random
and so people have used this idea of
rather than just having one reference
translation we could have multiple
reference translations because that way
we can allow for there being variation
and good ways of translating things
because in language there's always lots
of good ways that you can translate one
sentence people have done that too quite
a bit but people have also decided that
even if you have one translation
providing it's independent and on a kind
of statistical basis you're still more
likely to match it if your translation
is a good translation so it's probably
okay so when Bleu was originally
introduced Bleu seemed marvelous and
people drew graphs like this showing how
closely blue scores correlated with
human judgments of translation quality
however like a lot of things in life
there are a lot of things that are great
measures providing people aren't
directly trying to optimize it and so
what's happened since then is that
everybody has been trying to optimize
blue scores and the result of that is
that blue scores have gone up massively
but the correlation between blue scores
and human judgments of translation and
quality have gone down massively and so
we're in this current state that the
blue scores of machines are pretty near
the scores of human translation so you
know according to blue scores we're
producing almost human quality machine
translation but if you actually look at
the real quality of the translations
they're still well behind human beings
and because you could say the metric is
being gamed okay
I hope those things help for giving more
sense for assignment four so now for the
last about 12 minutes I just now want to
return to final projects and say a
little bit more about final projects so
there are many many different ways you
can do final projects but just to sort
of go through the steps I mean you know
for a simple straightforward project
this is kind of the steps that you want
to go through so you choose
some tasks summarizing text producing a
shorter version of a text you work out
some data set that you can use so this
is an example the kind of tasks that
there are academic datasets for that
other people have used and so you could
just use one of those and that you're
already done or you can think there are
no I'm much too creative for that I'm
going to come up with my own data set
and get some online source and do it and
you know summaries are the kind of
things you can find online and produce
your own data set I want to say a bit in
in just after this about separating off
data sets for training and test status
I'll delay that but that's important
then you want to work out a way to
evaluate your system including an
automatic evaluation normally for
summarization people use a slightly
different metric called Rouge but it's
sort of related to blue hence its name
it's the same story that it sort of
works but human evaluation is much
better but you need so you need to work
out some metrics you can use for the
project the next thing you should do is
establish a baseline so if the well
worked on problem they might already be
one but it's not bad to try and
calculate one for yourself anyway and in
particular what you should first have is
a very simple model and see how well it
works so for human language material
often doing things like bag-of-words
models whether they're just a simple
classifier over words or a neural bag of
words averaging word vectors it's just
useful to try that on the task and see
how it works see what kinds of things
that already gets right what kind of
things it gets wrong you know one
possibilities you'll find that a very
simple model already does great on your
task if that's the case you have two
easier tasks and you probably need to
find a task that's more challenging to
work on yeah so after that you'll then
sort of think about what could be a good
kind of neural network model that might
do well implement it test
see what kind of errors that makes and
you know that's sort of if you've gotten
that far you're sort of in the right
space for a class project but you know
it's sort of hoped that you can do more
than that that after you've seen the
errors from the first version you could
think about how to make it better and
come up with a better project and so I
would encourage everyone you know you
really do want to look at the data Hirai
if you don't just want to be sort of
having things and files and run and say
okay 0.71 let me make some random change
0.7 though that's not a good one repeat
over you actually want to be sort of
looking at your data set in any way you
can it's good to visualize the data set
to understand what's important in it
that you might be able to take advantage
of you want to be able to look at what
kind of errors are being made because
that might give you ideas of how you
could put more stuff into the model that
would do better you might want to do
some graphing of the effect of hyper
parameters so you can kind of understand
that better and so the hope is that you
can try out some other kinds of models
and make things better and sort of one
of the goals here is it's good if you've
sort of got a well set up experimental
setup so you can easily turn around
experiments because then you're just
more likely to be able to try several
things in the time available okay a
couple of other things I wanted to
mention one is sort of different amounts
of data so it's really really important
for all the stuff that we do that we
have different sets of data so we have
train data we have dev test data we have
test data at least and sometimes it's
useful to have even more data available
so for many of the public datasets
they're already split into different
subsets like this but there's some that
are there some that might only have a
training set and a test said and what
you don't want to do is think oh there's
only a training set and a test set
therefore I'll just run every time on
the test set now that's a really invalid
way to go about your research so if
there are divs sets available or you
need to do some more tuning and you need
some a separate tuning data you sort of
have to
and make it for yourself by splitting
off some of the training data and not
using it for the basic training and
using it for tuning and as dev data yeah
so to go on about that more more so the
basic issue is this issue of fitting and
overfitting to particular datasets so
when we train a model on some training
data we train it and the error rate goes
down and over time we gradually over fit
to the training data because we sort of
pick up on our neural network facts
about the particular training data items
and we just sort of start to learn them
now in the old days the fact that you
over fit to the training data was seen
as evil in modern neural network think
we don't think it as evil what we over
fit to the training data because all
neural nets that are any good over fit
to the training data and we would be
very sad if they didn't I'll come back
to that in a moment
but nevertheless their overfitting like
crazy so what we and what we want to
build is something that generalizes well
so we have to have some separate data
that's our validation data and say look
at what performance looks like on the
validation data and commonly we find
that training up until some point
improves our performance on separate
validation data and then we start to
overfit to the training data in a way
that our validation set performance gets
worse and so then further training on
the training data isn't useful because
we're starting to build a model that
generalizes worse when run on other data
but the whole point here is we can only
do this experiment if our validation
data is separate from our training data
if it's the same data or if it's
overlapping data we can't draw this
graph and so therefore we can't do valid
experiments now you might think oh well
maybe I can do this and just use the
test set of data
but that's also invalid and the reason
why that's invalid is as you do
experiments
you also start slowly overfitting to
your development data so the standard
practice is you do a run and you get a
score on the development data you do a
second run you do worse on the
development data and so you through that
second model away you do a third
experiment you do better on the
development data and so you keep that
model and you repeat over 50 times and
we'll some of those subsequent models
you keep are genuinely better because
you sort of worked out something good to
do but it turns out that some of those
subsequent models only sort of just
happened you just got lucky and they
happen to score better on the
development data and so if you kind of
keep repeating that process sixty a
hundred times you're also gradually
overfitting on your development data and
you get unrealistically good dev scores
and so that means two things you know if
you want to be rigorous into a huge
amount of hyper parameter exploration it
can be good to have a second development
test set so that you have one that you
haven't overfit as much and if you want
to have ballad scores on the on as to
what was my actual performance on
independent data it's vital that you
have separate test data that you're not
using at all in this process right so
the ideal stays is that for your real
test data that you never use it at all
until you're finished training your data
training your model and then you run
your final model once on the test data
and you write up your paper and those
are your results now I will be honest
and say the world usually isn't quite
that perfect because after you've done
that you then go to sleep and wake up
thinking I've got a fantastic idea of
how to make my model better and you run
off and implement that and it works
great on the dev data and then for you
run it on the test data again and the
numbers go up sort of everybody does
that and you know in modicum it's okay
you know if that means you occasionally
run on the test data is not so bad
but you really need to be aware of the
slippery slope because if you then start
falling into I've got a new model let me
try that one on the test day I only want
to try this one on the test data then
you're just sort of overfitting to the
test data and getting an unrealistically
high score and that's precisely why a
lot of the competitions like Kegel
competitions have a secret test data set
that you can't run on so that they can
do a genuine independent test on the
actual test data okay let's see couple
more minutes so yeah getting your neural
network to train my two messages are you
know first of all you should start with
a positive attitude neural networks want
to learn if they're not learning you're
doing something to stop them from
learning and so you should just stop
that and they will learn because they
want to learn they're just like little
children but you know if the follow-up
to that is the grim reality and there
are just tons of things you can do that
will cause your neural networks not to
learn very well
or at all and this is the frustrating
part of this whole field because you
know it's not like a compile error it
can just be hard to find and fix them
and you know it is just really standard
that you spend more time dealing with
trying to find and fix why it doesn't
work well on getting it to work well
then you then the time you spent writing
the code for your model so remember to
budget for that when you're doing your
final project it just won't work if you
finish the code a day or two before the
deadline so you need to work out what
those things are that can be hard but
you know experience experimental care
rules of thumb help so there are just
lots of things that are important so you
know your learning rates are important
if your learning rates are way too high
things won't learn if your learning rate
the way too low
they will learn very slowly and badly
initialization makes a difference having
good initialization often determines how
well neural networks
I have a separate slide here that I
probably haven't got time to go through
all of on sort of four sequence models
some of the tips of what people normally
think of good ways to get those models
working but I'll just say this one last
thing I think the strategy that you
really want to take is to work
incremental e and build up slowly it
just doesn't work to think oh I've got
the mother of all models and build this
enormous Lea complex thing and then run
it on the data and it crashes and burns
you have no idea what to do at that
point that the only good way is to sort
of build up slowly so start with a very
simple model get it to work
add your bells and whistles extra layers
and so on get them to work or abandon
them and so try and proceed from one
working model to another as much as
possible one of another way that you can
start small and build up is with data
the easiest way to see bugs and problems
in your model is with the my newest
possible amount of data so start with
the data set of eight items sometimes
it's even best if those eight items are
ones that are artificial data if you
designed yourself because then you can
often more easily see problems and
what's going wrong so you should train
on that because it's only eight items
training only takes seconds and that's
really really useful for how to iterate
quickly and you know if you can't have
your morale get a hundred percent
accuracy on training and testing on
those eight examples well you know
either model is woefully underpowered or
the model is broken and you've got clear
things to do right there when you go to
a bigger model you know the standard
practice with modern neural networks is
you want to train your models you want
models that can over fit massively on
the training set so in general your
models should still be getting close to
100% accuracy on the training set after
you've trained it for a long time
because powerful neural network models
are just really good at overfitting too
and memorizing data
if that's not the case well you know
maybe you want a bigger model maybe you
want to have a higher hidden dimensions
or add an extra layer on your network or
something like that you shouldn't be
scared of overfitting on the training
data but once you've proved you can do
that you then do want a model that also
generalize as well and so normally the
way that you're addressing that is then
by regularizing their model and there
are different ways to regularize your
model but we talked about in the
assignment doing drop out I mean using
generous drop out is one very common and
effective strategy for regularizing your
models and so then your what you want to
be doing is regularizing your model
enough that the curve no longer looks
like this but instead that your
validation performance kind of levels
out but doesn't start ramping back up
again and that's then a sort of a sign
of a well regularize model okay I will
stop there and then we'll come back to
the question answering project on
Thursday